all right so welcome to
the um final afternoon I'm very happy we
have so um hi Mart um thank you all for
coming and uh a big thanks to Simons for
uh giving a big boost to our
field and uh uh it's really a privilege
to have such a wonderful resource of
course Cs and econ and other fields
so okay so I'm going to talk about uh uh
is the volume okay yeah so I'm going to
talk about the core which is which is a
quintessential solution Concept in
economics as well as Game
Theory um it was defined uh an early
version with a different name was
defined by Edgeworth in the 19th century
in the context of General equ ibrium
Theory and then in 59 it was ported to
Cooperative Game Theory by gues and
there its status
grew year after year I I guess more or
less or maybe at least decade after
decade and uh LP Duality theory has been
used all the way from the beginning till
now and
uh uh in the context of this book I
started looking at this more carefully
and I could find many gaps remaining
more than one let's say and that's what
I want to talk about today what are the
gaps and how somebody can fill them so
um I'm not giving any definitions for a
while uh I think in the style of Al Roth
uh keep it without symbols for as long
as possible um so so just a high level
uh picture here um so this is the famous
bonda shley theorem it was proved
independently by Olga bonda in the
Soviet Union then the Soviet Union and
Lloyd shley in the US um around the same
time actually bonda did it earlier um
and you know that in those in that era
there used to be key results that would
be proved on both sides of the Iron
Curtain quite independently and almost
at the same time I guess because the
time was ripe for the result so so many
of
those so what it says is that a game has
a non-empty core if and only if it is
balanced I'm not even going to defined
balanced I haven't defined the core I
know don't worry about it non-mt of
course everybody knows and that's a very
key property about a game to a certain
whether or not a game has an empty core
um and its proof is follows from
forecast LMA namely LP
Duality and uh this condition of
balancedness involves all subsets of
Agents so exponentially many subsets and
therefore exponentially many variables
in the
lp and so the lp is
humongous and uh that by itself is not a
showstopper to good algorithms but on
top of that it has it is structur less
so for instance non- bipartite matching
Edmund's LP has exponentially many
constraints one for every odd set but
you can solve it using ellipsoid you can
solve it comor very very fast but here
as far as I know this theorem which is a
key theorem because it Asser something
very key about the core namely
non-emptiness of the
core has no algorithms around it it's
never got used in an algorithm okay
because of
this this this this mess this mess that
it it it it it involves exponentially
many
variables on the other hand uh CH shubik
did study the core the right way using
LP Duality and there's this considered
really a classic
paper um probably most economists I
think I've never met an economist who
didn't put it in their top few papers I
hope I never do uh so that I mean top
few papers might include Nash
equilibrium market equilibrium and this
and maybe a few more so I'm going to
start by deconstructing this result
before constructing something new around
these
Notions okay so and again I'm not going
to give any definitions for a while for
quite a while uh and we'll just do fun
and games and uh importantly uh you're
welcome to stop me anytime and ask any
questions or make any comments and uh I
know I have 45 minutes but it'll we have
times okay so so here's a um a tennis
club which has some rather famous uh
play players and uh there are women
players and Men players and each Edge
means that they can uh form a team and
enter into a tournament that's about to
happen and these are the expected
winnings of each team if they enter the
tournament and uh of course the the
tennis club for its own Survival would
like to put in a bunch of teams that
maximize the earnings and that can be
done by picking picking teams that Maxim
maximize the weight of the matching
formed and that would be these two teams
the two green teams because then the
earnings would be
250 $220 so also you can you can uh
please question my arithmetic because
it's not it's quite weak okay so
uh so so how to distribute this profit
of $220
right and I already flashed this slide
that it a fair solution would be to
equally divide it and of course nobody's
happy with this even Chris ever is not
happy because you know it's hurts her
Pride to get uh free
money so what should we
do any alternatives well let's see what
what what we should do there are
alternatives there not very good and I
would put them all under the uh heading
of uh naive Fair Solutions we don't want
to go there we want some really
sophisticated Fair solutions for profit
sharing okay and we'll do it via a
negotiation based process because these
are probably the most competitive people
on this planet and each of think them
thinks they are the best player ever and
should get the entire profit right so
they should fight it out that's the only
way to get to a real solution and that's
that's not an if solution okay so it
should be a negotiation based
process and uh this is too complicated
an example so we have to start somewhere
simple and here we have uh two possible
teams uh and $100 can be made whether we
enter the Green Team or the black team
and let's say we enter the Green Team
and how you going to share the profit of
the green team right between Serena and
Beyond Borg okay so Borg says well I was
by are the best player in the era of
wooden rackets I should get the whole
profit and Serena says look I know I
retired now but I was the best woman
player for two decades and uh and if
you're not happy with zerar go sit on
the sideline and Jimmy Corners will come
and play with me okay and indeed she
gets the whole profit and these guys get
zero profit the reason being that she's
good of course and the men have no
Alternatives she has alternatives
if you have Alternatives you can
negotiate if you have no Alternatives
you take what you
get okay let's go to a oh then Connor
UPS his team his game and now with
Serena they can make
$110 how should they divide the profit
and Conor said look I have been really
working hard give me half the profit at
least we have made more money and she
says well take $10 otherwise I'm going
to play with Borg who's sitting on the
sideline and that's how the profits get
divided
okay so let's I mean these are too
simple an example so again the same
reason um so now we have a bit more
complex situation and we can have two
kind two two ways of uh entering teams
with maximum weight matching either the
black teams or the green teams and both
give equal profit to the to the tennis
club and suppose we enter the green
teams so Serena plays with John mackenro
and Martina plays with Jimmy corners and
here you can see that by far the best
player is me Andro right no matter who
he plays with he makes
$110 um and you probably know how he
wins so much money uh he always screams
at the referees and uh and you know they
give him the points but that's besides
the point the point is he makes money he
should get
profits and uh if he asks for lots of
profit William says okay go sit on the S
line I can easily make $100 playing with
Bor who who will get
Epsilon and so the profit of 210 again
gets divided in a very lopsided way
that's the only way to do it a
negotiation based
process so what's going on here okay and
this time of course mechro has
Alternatives so you thought alternatives
are good but his his alternatives are
are uh not as good as as the positional
advantage that Serena and Martina have
because they have players sitting there
waiting to to play with her for Z right
so so there's a lot going on here and uh
and if you want to analyze this game oh
my God it'll be it'll be a big mess so
let's put in some uh real systematic uh
uh solution concept here to get to these
kinds of nice uh ways of allocating
profit and uh so this is the assignment
game the classic work of shapley and
shubik and the underlying mathematical
structure is that there's a bipartite
graph these are the women players the
men players and the teams and the
profits of the of each team
right and the grand Coalition of course
is the all the players these are all
possible teams and W is the expected
earning off a team and and the profit of
the whole game which is called the worth
of the game is the is the max weight
matching in this in this graph and the
question is how to distribute the
worth and and that's what brings me to
this topic of profit sharing which is uh
really a central uh concern ever since
Humanity became somewhat
intelligent so and and and the proof of
that lies in this amazing paper of omen
and
mashor uh can so so bankruptcy problem
from the talmud and what is that so
there's an incident from this Babylonian
talmud from 500
BC um so there's this man who has three
wives um apparently it was allowed then
um and uh uh he is going to he's trying
to promise uh this wives some wealth
after his death okay now um I I don't
know what currency they were using in
the Babylonian old ancient Babylonian
time but you know my civilization is
even older so I'm going to use rupees
okay so let's say that he promises to
these three wives 100 200 and 300 rupees
fair enough okay so 100 200 and 300
rupees and uh and then if when he passes
away his estate is worth 100 200 or 300
rupees the question is how much should
each wife get and the recommendation
from the Babylonian tmot is not 1 is to
2 is to3 ratio no basically the the the
what they get turns out to be consistent
with What's called the nucleus which is
also a solution concept for profit
sharing inferior to core core is the
gold
standard nucleus has many problems I
don't want to go into that at all so so
but but but but I I I hope you realize I
mean if if you don't share profit in a
Fair Way um basically um loving siblings
can stop talking friends can become
enemies entire business collaborations
can collapse and you know nothing will
get done and uh probably that was seen
in the Congress recently uh nothing was
done for three weeks okay I don't know I
I don't want to go into those issues
here good morning uh so um so the core
as I said is the is the um basic uh the
the gold standard for profit sharing and
it tries to make sure that the grand
Coalition remains intact in what sense
in the sense that no sub Coalition can
generate more profit by
itself by itself whatever the profit it
can generate right and therefore will
not feel any need for to succeed and
therefore the core uh therefore the
grand Collision remains
intact so let's define all of this stuff
also properly so a subc will be some
subset of players men and women and the
worth of a subc is a weight of Max
weight matching in the graph restricted
to the players in s and of course the
worth of the entire game is the the
total
profit and an imputation is a way of
sharing the worth among all the players
the worth of the game of course right
and what we want to do is make sure that
every sub Coalition gets at least as
much money as it can make by the itself
and that comes about like this that an
imputation is in the core first of all
it if it divides the total worth among
the players and for every sub coalation
the amount of money obtained by the
players in the subc is at least the max
weight matching in G restricted to S
okay so then the question arises what
kind of a fairness criteria does this
way of sharing the profit satisfy what
is this fairness criteria and obviously
it is fair to each of the exponentially
many
subal that's what it is right but it has
some drawbacks
also beautiful and wonderful as it is it
has some drawbacks for instance in the
assignment
game uh the an individual player so a
coll consisting of only a one man or a
one one woman makes can make zero money
because you need an ENT team to enter
into the
tournament and so it makes no promises
to individual players is that
okay not really and we'll see what can
be done about
that questions somebody had no sorry
somebody should have huh did you define
the term Fair uh whatever you think it
is in English
language this this this is the notion of
fair
that that it gives to each sub Coalition
as much money as it can make by itself
and that's the notion of fairness at
that it satisfies now I I cannot unravel
that
more but we can talk about it
later okay
so uh let's see what Shepley and chupik
did um so they characterized the core of
the assignment game how so they first
wrote out the lp relaxation of the
problem of finding a max weight matching
in the underlying graph on the men and
the women players and this is you know
it looks like a whole bunch of dirty
symbols but but it's not very hard it's
quite easy actually so all you have is
this is a weight which is the profit of
a team e this is a a variable
corresponding to each each team e and
what it says is that the total and these
variables should take on values non-
negative values they never have to take
a value more than one because of these
con straints and these simply say that
at each um woman player and at each man
player at most one total Edge should be
incident when added over all the
fractions so this gives you a fractional
matching and the amazing thing about
this LP is that it always has an
integral optimal solution so that's a
real matching not a fractional matching
anymore and that's that's okay I don't
know how shle should be chose this
problem whether the revers engineered to
this or they started with this and
realized that there was integrality and
then went forward with that but but
that's the Magic in this LP and then
they wrote out the Dual so there's a
variable y sub I for each of these
inequalities y subj for each of these
inequalities and you're minimizing the
sum of these y's and this is the the key
point that
each each team should get at least as as
much profit as it can generate by
itself okay so for each Edge i j the
total profit of I and J is at least the
weight of that edge it's a covering LP
this is a packing LP um non negativity
nothing more so incredibly enough if you
make teams happy you make every sub
coalation happy and that's what the she
shic theorem says that that why is a
core imputation if only if it is an
optimal dual solution so very statement
right I mean complete characterization
of the core and that's not always I mean
in fact very rarely is it possible to
completely characterize or even uh and
okay so I'll say more so and the and of
course LP Duality theorem has to give
the proof and so the core is non-empty
so the game is balanced but we don't
care for that and being non-empty the
code being non-empty is somewhat rare
because exponentially many sub
corelations have to be happy
okay
so turns out these solutions that we got
from negotiation are the unique
imputations in the course of these two
games that I that I gave unique
imputations okay so there's some big
Power here going on and uh indeed from
this it should be obvious that the core
gives deep insights into negotiating
power of individuals and sub I'm not
sure individuals in this case but in
general
um and the core is a convex polytope
because it consists of all the optimal
dual
Solutions uh and I just showed you two
examples where the core is has only one
point in it but when it is non-unique it
has two very special imputations one
favors the women players and one favors
the men players okay and for instance in
this game uh Jimmy Conor got $10 this is
the man optimal imputation and that's
the woman optimal imputation where
Serena gets in fact all the money and
every com convex combination of these
two is a core imputation and that's it
that's the whole core in this game yeah
okay so what is the underlying reason
for these two extreme imputations and
I'm sure you will be recalling stable
matching and we'll come to that in a
moment because that also has two extreme
Solutions so shley and Chic showed that
the set of code imputations form a
Distributive
lattice and the the extreme imputations
are the top and the bottom element of
this
lattice okay and you know this this uh
uh setting of uh of assignment game
turned out to be paradigmatic because
you know the wonderful structural
properties completely everything works
out and that's of course the Testament
to matching and its wonderful structure
which always amazes people um
and and and in in fact I showed it to
you in the context of the of a very
frivolous uh tennis game but they give
it in the context of a housing market
game ah which is shown in the cover of
this new book um so this is somewhere
close to my house in uh Newport Beach
where they are trying to find out which
is more valuable a house or a rock and
in this case the house turns out to be
less valuable than the Rock okay and if
you're thinking if you're saying hey hey
you know if you uh you have any pity on
me that's not my house okay somebody
else's house turns out to be like that
uh I don't know who moreover okay but
the point is that uh that uh what the
point I want to make is that this
housing market game however nice it is
and however many applications it can
have simple ones is is a bit oops is a
somewhat rudimentary and we'll see how
to fix that
also okay so as far as I know and you
can correct me at the end of the talk or
maybe now as far as I know the
core uh the assignment game was was
studied by Chipley and Chik they started
studying it and they got essentially all
the wonderful properties of this game I
don't I haven't seen a single paper that
comes to the level of this level of
fundamental properties I but I might be
mistaken and you can correct me later or
now so but still we are allowed to ask
this question right do we really know it
all and let's see what we might know
about the assignment game beyond what
Shepley and shupik did so here's a
question which players get
profits which players get
profits uh can we characterize the set
of players who get profits
okay so let's uh let's try to attempt an
answer so I'm going to uh classify
players into three categories essential
ones are matched in every max weight
matching okay they have to play viable
ones are matched in some max weight
matchings and not matched in some other
max weight matchings and subpar ones are
never matched in max weight
matchings so which players get profits
essential viable subar or essential and
viable each one of those players at
least
once I don't know if I should ask such a
high powerered audience for answers but
if you want to venture and answer please
go
ahead only this time after this I'll ask
many questions and answer them
myself just because it's the first
question I'm asking so far get zero okay
and who gets positive profits somebody
else should answer
that you don't want to take the risk
very
smart
okay nobody want to I don't care you
know
huh oh really good okay no you're right
okay so but what will give the answer
what will give the answer is the
following thought that the worth of the
game comes from an optimal solution to
the Primal
LP a core imputation comes from an
optimal solution to the Dual LP what
connects a primal optimal solution to a
dual optimal
solution huh MERS complimentary flatness
conditions we call it in computer
science and and and for people in
approximation algor this is sort of uh
you know bread and butter you wake up in
the middle of the night and you'd be
thinking about complimentary flatness
conditions so surprising it is that
nobody applied complimentary slackness
conditions to this for 60 years but if
you apply it you get to this theorem
that a player is paid in some core
imputation if and only if it is
essential
and uh in other words core imputations
play only essential players and every
essential player gets in some core
imputation okay we'll use this we'll use
these facts in a
moment okay
so and then one can talk about teams and
apply complimentary slackness conditions
to teams and all that but that's not
part of the this talk okay so let's now
jump to stable matching which is has
some analogous properties namely it also
has uh these extreme Solutions because
of uh because the set of stable matching
form the distributive lce the only
difference is that this time it's a
finite distributive lce there's not a
small difference as we'll see in a
moment and the Gil shepple U defer
accepts algorithm finds exactly these
two solutions nothing in the middle
depending on who
proposes and both both of them are
extreme solutions they favor one side
and disfavor the other side and so you
want to you want to find more fair
Solutions and a lot of work was done on
that
uh yeah a lot of work on was done on
that um using boff representation
theorem for finite distributive latices
and the notion of rotations so
the Burk of representation theorem says
that corresponding to any finite
distributive lce there's a partial order
on some elements such that the upper
Clos sets of that partial order which by
themselves form a lce these upper Clos
sets are isomorphic two elements inside
the lattice okay and in the case of
stable matching the the partial order
the elements on which the partial order
is defined are the rotations and there
are at most n Square rotations so this
is a suin rep representation of the
entire lce which may be exponentially
large but this particular partial order
is on over only at most n Square
vertices elements so using these
rotations you can go and and this
particular partial order you can go from
the top element to the bottom element
each time improving one side and and and
decreasing the other side and so
somewhere in the middle you might be
able to find better more fair uh stable
matching than that and there are many
results giving those
algorithms so let's see what happens in
the case of core of the assignment game
again we have top and bottom element and
these can be found using LP very easily
um can we find more fair core
amputations problem L is not finite in
fact the core is very dense not very
dense but it is dense I don't know what
very dense
means
[Music]
so
so the lce is not
finite so it's a Distributive lce but
not finite so uh sorry I drank it in a
hurry um and as a result burkov
representation theorem doesn't hold and
so we need new methodology if we want to
find somewhere some some core
imputations that are more fair to both
sides right so what can we do besides
right what what is what kind of new
methodology can we throw at this issue
is it clear what the issue is yeah well
in this case have we told us how to get
top and bottom I I told you some LP can
do it yeah very easy I mean homework
exercise I mean really honestly for you
you'll step out of it and and get it on
the way okay so basically we need new
methodology if you want to find these
Warfare core
imputations right and and I'll show you
one way that I can do it but I'm sure
that many more things have to be done or
should be done here I hope okay because
it seems like the kind of thing
that many more things need to be done
okay so first of all how about getting a
min max Fair core imputation okay so so
let CI be the set of all core
imputations of instance eye of
assignment
game and and the minmax fair core
imputation is the one that minimizes
over
all
imputations the maximum over all players
of the amount of money the player gets
minimize the maximum amount that any
player
gets okay and lo and behold there's a
very easy LP that solves this namely you
first solve an LP to determine the worth
of the game that's one LP the Dual
and then Alpha will be squished down
from the top zero is here we'll squish
down Alpha as much as possible and make
sure that all players get at most Alpha
and these these two conditions ensure
that this is a an optimal dual because
it has the right objective function
value and the right uh constraints on on
on
edges and so we'll get a yes sir so in
compatibility is
right so if you have a onesided
assignment
Market yeah PR in core then would also
be incentive compatible but that is not
a concern no not yet I mean I want to
just optimize the the money money spent
money profit given but let's talk more I
I I I I like where you're heading but
but it's for a longer discussion yeah
thank you for asking that so so so so so
yeah we have non- negativity and these
two conditions ensure that this is a uh
an optimal dual solution and then upon
that we are minimizing Alpha so
therefore we'll minimize the max right
okay how about Max men well not not that
much far removed because uh we we Define
that to be the one that the core
imputation that maximizes over all
imputations in the core the minimum
amount that a player gets and clearly
there's a similar LP that will do it
right yes do it but will it do anything
useful that's the question what do I
mean by that so this amount the amount
of money given to a player the minimum
amount of money that a player gets can
it be identical identically zero so that
the max of this Min is zero and we get
zero it's a vacus
solution right could it be
that and the answer is yes it could be
because if there's a non-essential
player that player will get zero always
in every core imputation so the max of
the Min is
zero there's a player who always gets
zero so the minimum is always zero so
the max of the Min is always zero so you
got nothing out of this
solution right so how do we fix it
obviously we should change it so that we
only think about essential players
because they get positive money and we
minimize over only the essential players
and then we can write out an
LP but we want to still be careful right
we maybe maybe maybe no matter which
core imputation I take there's always an
essential player who gets
zero right so if for every core
imputation there's always a an essential
player not we know there could be a
player who gets zero non-essential ones
but there could also be an essential
player who always for each code
imputation there's an essential player
who get zero in which case this is still
identically zero how do we deal with
that
so remember I said that each essential
player gets in some core
imputation so for each essential player
pick that core imputation and take the
the convex combination of those core
imputations that's still a core
imputation and under that core
imputation every essential player gets
non-zero amount and therefore
this is not identically zero so it's not
vacuous this this this notion is not
vacuous
so therefore we can also find Max Min
and that'll be somewhere between the top
and the
bottom can we do more yes uh oh and and
it's an LP that's similar I won't go
there so we can find an equitable core
imputation how do I Define that yes sir
this
um instead of selecting AER you select a
oh no no no no no no you can get to the
set of essential players I'll tell you
how you know the worth of the game right
you know the worth of the game now pull
out a player find the worth of the
remaining game if it did not go out go
down this is not essential if it went
down then then this is essential so if
you do that for each player you got the
set of essential players everything is
polinomial time
here true of the master we didn't need
to go there we didn't need to go
there there's an asymmetry here uh
there's a very subtle asymmetry and
that's the reason I stated that
first because there we didn't even
random we are not choosing any player at
random sorry no we are not choosing
anything at
random
uh so your question is why is minmax
okay okay why is minmax okay and the
reason is that these inequalities can be
thrown in for for for free the and the
these will just s squish the the top
element
down that's it so so we don't need to
essential players have no meaning no
extra meaning here essential players
will have non zero but everybody will
have at least zero and therefore we are
okay
okay it's a easy thought for later let's
talk later
yeah possible that core is not unique of
course we talk single essential player
who gets the same $100 in a core we saw
that happen Serena Williams was that
player but that if the core is unique
and there's a single essential player
there's nothing to be found there's no
that's why I'm saying it's not unique
when single player is getting $100 at
all Coreal locations what would that
find sorry it's if the core is unique
not unique how is it not unique if a
single player gets $100 everybody else
gets zero which get something how do you
mean there something only essential
players get something so there are more
essential players than that one person
who's getting
100 maybe no no no so so think about it
the question was not well posed the
question is uh you always get $100
whatever core I I always get some core
allocations I get only 20 and another
some another cor I get only 50 yeah okay
right right good so then then you have
multiple multiple yeah what what would
that which one I I first of all uh if
the game decomposes into disjoint things
only then you can have one player who
gets always a
100 but that's besides the point I don't
even want to decompose it okay because
that's like a small trick okay but
everything will work out with this let's
talk later but but but may I think it's
a sorry I I was wrong it's not a I said
it's not a well poos no it's not not a
well post problem so it's a wellos
problem but but it has an easy answer
let's let's come to that
yeah okay so what else can we do well so
what we can do
is Equitable core imputations what are
these so it's let's define the spread of
a core imputation to be the difference
between the maximum profit and the
minimum profit and try
to minimize the
spread the difference between the
maximum profit of an of an agent and the
minimum and of course here again the
minimum we can only do it we we only
need to do do these over essential
players otherwise we can run into the
same problems as before and no need to
go there two times okay not for this
audience at least so and there's a big
fat LP that does it but no need to go
there either okay so sh shik is great
everybody agrees to that okay and it has
even more properties than than we sort
of thought of I don't know if you think
of this as good or not or there's more
work to be done all of those are valid
questions but the big question is going
forward what makes this theorem
tick right why does this theorem have so
much power the shapely shubik theorem
okay and the reason is exactly what I've
been saying so far that this LP first of
all it is polinomial sized it's not like
shapley shubik oh no bonda Shepley and
secondly it always has an integral
optimal solution so for instance suppose
you are given this bipartite graph on
four uh teams and four
players and every team's profit is
$1 then you could be matching half of
this player to half of this half of this
to half of this and so on and therefore
getting a total profit of two but if
there is such a matching which which is
a fractional matching then there's also
one matching that matches these two
players only or these two players only
so this is an integral matching and that
always holds in a bipartite graph
there's always an integral optimal
matching okay and that's great because
of course we don't want to cut up the
players and send half of the player here
and half of the player there right that
will not be fair or maybe not even legal
sorry so uh so the answer is integrality
okay great and as soon as we go to non-
bipar graph unit weight edges over a
triangle then the optimal fractional
matching is half half half which is one
and a half optimal integral matching is
strictly smaller the core of this game
is empty and one way to repair it using
Notions from approximation algorithms
for NP hard problems is to come up with
a two3 approximate code imputation
always
works and why did I say NP hard problems
in
red yeah oh three minutes no no okay
okay because because because there's
nothing NP hard here okay so so the
underlying reason for NP is for
integrality is integrality means that
all vertices are integral of the of the
polytope okay and the underlying reason
for integrality is to unim modity of the
constraint Matrix okay and by Ker's rule
it gives integrality and can we
generalize this so some people got to
this answer already but they didn't
generalize it all the way and then
there's there's more to be done namely
the B can also be an integral vector and
so so B matching also works out and then
but can we go even further and there's a
beautiful theorem from 56 of Hoffman and
crll giving a necessary and sufficient
condition for integral it based on total
unimodality and that gave me this game
uh which is a much more General version
much more General than the housing game
and here the edge variables can be it
can be used for many many applications
um not many many many but maybe one or
two school choice and doctors and uh and
and uh and there the edges can help
enforce diversity and avoid Mis over
representation and then uh there must be
other to un model games because I've
only looked at matching which is 01 and
that comes to flow games where which was
given actually by Kay and ZL uh where
they only gave one core imputation and
then one can get more core imputations
because that's important because you can
get Fair core imputations very easily
and this has many many applications Max
flow has many many applications can we
go even further yes we can go even
further so we have come to the edge of
total unimodality can we go go even
further yes we we can go to Total dual
integrality and this is where I really
want to spend a minute so so I gave uh
something that I called the investment
management
game um and uh it is uh defined over
perfect graphs for which finding a max
weight independent set is in P believe
it or not that's NP hard in general okay
and uh and this is not a a a a a
Cooperative game at all it's a game
against nature okay okay and this
Investment Management game will not help
anybody you know uh do anything good
about their investment in fact if you
use it you bound to run into big losses
so don't ever go there but the reason
for this game is that it shows the
verality of the notion of core because
so far the core was only used for profit
and cost sharing and utility sharing and
that's not good enough for such a big
beautiful concept it should have more
diverse applications and that was was
the reason for this paper and uh Nash
equilibrium which is certainly a much
more important solution concept than
core maybe core is the second most
important has huge versatility if you
just look at bietrix games you know
prisoners dilemma matching pennies um
Battle of sexes rock paper scissor
everyone has a different meaning okay
and beyond that so why is it that code
is stuck only on these profit sharing
and cost sharing that was the reason to
do this and and I told you that the code
was by Edgeworth taken to Cooperative
games in in general equilibrium Theory
then taken to Cooperative games by gues
and then the question is does it want to
go somewhere else because this is not an
Cooperative game at all and it's
definitely an application of the notion
of core so I don't know where it wants
to go I don't even know if if anybody
believes in what I'm done because
there's no applications of uh these
investment you you certainly don't want
to go near that if you're anywhere close
to Wall Street um and uh I don't know
how many people have the Cycles to spend
on such a far out thing but I hope it
goes somewhere I don't know okay that's
all thank
[Music]
you we have one more
question
yeah a quick question if
possible I'll get rid of this
let